hey what up Swede cook 84 here back
again with another video that's right I
really just wanted to make a video a
follow-up video over the video I made
what was the cold [ __ ] I don't remember
I've been doing YouTube for seven years
and I guess I'm really just tired of
being in try hard mode tired of trying
that's right I'm tired of trying it's
kind of video I was really nervous about
uploading because I didn't know what
sort of reaction it would get but I
gotta say it was truly heartwarming to
see how you guys understood where I was
coming from and appreciating my honesty
with a situation basically I've been
sort of treating YouTube as a as a
startup almost like I've been working
crazy hours just stressing out over it
for such a long time and I I just
realize I'm in a position where I just I
want to take it a little bit more chill
and my approach this week to making
videos has really just been like what do
I feel like doing today do I feel like
making this kind of video and not really
but it would probably get more views
Elda I've just been focusing on what I
personally find really interesting or
fun to do I'm just really really glad
that you guys enjoy that [ __ ] cuz it's
stuff that I enjoy making it's sort of
like a new direction of the channel the
fact that you guys enjoyed it really
really really means a lot because I just
because I feel like I want to try and
less hard doesn't mean I don't care as
much anymore I really still do care a
lot about you bros that's not a pretty
gay you guys are okay I guess is what
I'm trying to say I really been enjoying
the player unknown videos you guys seem
to as well I really been enjoying the
fan interaction videos you guys seen as
well and I really been joined just
sharing and reacting to stuff that I
personally find really interesting and
you guys have as well really just the
only point in this video is just for me
to say thank you because I think it's
really cool to have an audience that
understands and respects me I know maybe
that's obvious but I really don't think
it's the case for a lot of people on
YouTube looking back at how I was
treating YouTube a couple
months ago it's very different from now
I had an office I had couple employees I
had I was running a business on the side
I was doing all these projects but I
found that these were all just things I
thought I had that I thought I needed
personally because I thought I had to be
more professional but I think in in
reality the more I try to be a
professional the more I sort of lost
touch in just the direct connection with
with what's so good about YouTube and
the direct connection with your audience
it sort of became layers upon myself and
I don't know why I thought that was a
good idea like obviously that's a
terrible idea
and personally these weren't even things
I liked it to begin with I don't like to
travel and do other things I don't like
to do other projects that I don't really
care about but they'll bring in money
these past two weeks have I've been so
much happier as a person I've been so
less stressed out just chill
I feel really good and and I don't think
I would be unless you guys was on the
same page as me is what I'm trying to
say I don't know I don't know what's
next to be honest I'm just gonna keep
doing what I feel like doing that's
really the plan here but I love the
videos because they feel more like me
than they did before because I
passionately enjoy playing Pat and
battlegrounds and I really love [ __ ]
[ __ ] on different things so I feel
like I'm back in a way I don't know if
that makes any sense I'm probably just
rambling at this point but at the end I
just want to say domo arigato thank you
for being a sister Fister and letting me
be the kind of channel that I want it to
be I wouldn't be here without you so I'm
never going to ignore you guys but at
the same time like I said I really
appreciate that you guys still respect
where I want to take things that's all I
don't want to get too mopey and [ __ ]
thank you guys so much
Domo Domo Domo and I'll see you brush
tomorrow with another video and as
always
sister-sister